[Applause]
they've kept a vigil night and day
trying to stop the count continuing in
the democrats stronghold of las vegas
nevada remaining blue overwhelmingly on
votes counted here
the trump supporters of the smallest
remaining undecided state
are determined in their belief that
there has been a fraud
by the morning far away in the east of
the united states
the call was made for biden these people
are scared of what may happen alien to
us but common here
it brings guns onto the streets
while small in number their vigil
continues
republicans like brandon believe that
this election
was stolen to think that this election
has any sort of credibility is just
ridiculous you can't put out a
multi-million dollar smear campaign
and then send out tens of millions of
ballots and
uh think that the the numbers are going
to come back accurately at all
um and to think that covet is a
legitimate excuse when everybody's going
to the grocery store
everybody's already wearing their masks
and all that kind of stuff it's a normal
thing
we should be able to go stand in line
and vote
regardless that there's no evidence of
corruption national
protest groups like stop the steel
campaign
aren't stopping i think there's still a
fight to be had
you know if you go and take a look at
president trump's statement that he made
this morning there's a written statement
where they are going to be starting
monday filing different lawsuits and a
lot of litigation so i think there's a
long
battle ahead and that's going to be
going to the courts
trump has been omnipresent in so many
walks of life
throughout the united states and indeed
across the world
his name won't disappear but on las
vegas boulevard
the party got underway only a few like
him here they're still shouting they
just aren't being listened to
i'm laughing at you i'm laughing at you
in their cars horns honking the
celebrations
in a town known for its party there was
a sense of relief
but nevada was a close election it
shouldn't be forgotten
for all the jubilation of the democrat
supporters very very pleased at a biden
victory
you can't forget that this was a really
close election here in nevada
there's an awful lot of trump fans still
who are very very angry
that is going to be the job for biden to
try and get the country back together
[Music]
[Applause]
the hardcore trumpers may never come
back into the fold of course
but many will trying to heal the
divisions
will start when the litigation stops
[Music]
stuart ramsey sky news las vegas